mind your decisions I'm presh tal Walker
in a circle a Pentagon is inscribed
opposite vertex a is side a will use
this convention to label the entire
Pentagon ABCDE draw side BD and see a
show that side a divided by the sine of
angle B plus angle E is equal to site D
divided by the sine of angle C plus
angle E like in the sign rule the vertex
name represents the angle at that vertex
this question was asked in the 2019 HSC
extension to mathematics exam question
16 Part C it was the last question in a
test given to year 12 students in
Australia who are about 16 to 18 years
old pause the video if you'd like to
give this problem a try and when you're
ready keep watching to learn how to
solve this problem
[Music]
there's a lot going on in the diagram so
let's focus on triangle BCD by l2 C's
law of sines side a divided by the sine
of the opposite angle CBD is equal to
side e divided by its opposite angle BD
c we have a similar equation in triangle
ABC side e
divided by its opposite angle is equal
to side e divided by its opposite angle
let's now take a look at these two
equations we're going to notice
something that relates them in
particular angle BAC is an inscribed
angle of arc BC an angle BD c is an
inscribed angle of the same arc
therefore these two angles are equal to
each other because their inscribed
angles of the same arc will make this
substitution in this equation and
therefore the right hand sides will be
equal to each other we thus can equate
the left hand sides of these equations
this is quite similar to what we need to
prove but we need to change the angles
in the denominators so let's consider
quadrilateral abde angle abd plus angle
e is equal to 180 degrees this is
because opposite angles in a cyclic
quadrilateral are supplementary you
could just cite this on the exam but if
you've never seen it let me show you a
quick proof will consider the arcs of
these inscribed angles here we have one
arc and the inscribed angle will be half
its measure angle e will be half the
measure of abd
now we will add these angles together
and half the measure of these arcs but
the total measure of these arcs together
will be equal to 360 degrees because
they span the entire circle when we make
that substitution and then divide by two
we get that opposite angles in a cyclic
quadrilateral are supplementary we
subtract angle E from both sides and we
get the equation that we want now we can
do a similar sort of thing in this
cyclic quadrilateral angle ACD will be
equal to 180 degrees minus E that's
because opposite angles in a cyclic
quadrilateral are supplementary so how
does this help us derive what we need to
get while angle CBD is equal to B minus
angle abd we substitute in what we
derived and then we simplify this
equation we then take the sine of both
sides use the sum of angles identity to
get the sine of theta plus 180 degrees
will be negative sine of theta therefore
the left hand side is negative sine of
angle CBD now we will derive a similar
equation from the cyclic quadrilateral a
CDE angle ACB is equal to C minus angle
ACD we then substitute in what we
derived and then simplify this equation
take the sine of both sides then use the
sum formula so the left-hand side
becomes negative sine of angle ACB we're
almost there we multiply the top
equation by negative one on both sides
we then substitute in what we derived
and we get what we need to show and
that's going to be it QED I think this
was an incredible question because you
really have to know your geometry and
trigonometry to get the final proof
thanks for making mind your decisions
one of the best channels on YouTube as
always thanks for watching and thanks
for your support
[Music]